ba ba du podium et voir s'ils vont et
moderne
on travaille en format a4 ces normes le
seul animateur au monde mais y'a qu'un
tunisien comme moi qui peut avoir des
feuilletons
c'est comme à l'école quand j'entendais
mes copines avait toujours de l'huile
dessus sur ma vie c'est vrai voilà c'est
horrible j'ai toujours était sale
alors on commence et que le ba ba du
poste du meilleur tacle les nommés sont
ces partis
[Musique]
jean michel maire sur daniel moreau est
ce que quelqu'un vous intéresse dans
l'équipe toujours pas à imager hmi jeu
avait commencé quelque chose on l'a fait
[Rires]
camille combal sur jean-michel mais où
est-ce que tu trouve tout ça c'est une
entente
[Rires]
et claude alexis sur matthieu delormeau
est-ce que donc dans trois ans si j'ai
su ce que vous avez dit je moi métier de
leur mauvais récupérer la case d'access
sur ces 8 6 1
il a pris c'était en trois ans c'est un
peu là mais est ce que quand tu vas
partir je vais le remplacer à 19h sur
scène le papa du mur patrimoine pas pour
qu'ils s'étaient posés qui pour toi pour
moi c'est pas dieu le sait pas de l'or
mais c'est de guerre si l'idée est pour
vous moi ces deux langues
ouais donc à claude alexis d'alexis qui
me réussit pas mal
par ailleurs on passe au deuxième babana
semaine le ba ba du poste du meilleur
déguisement gars
[Musique]
mercedes c'est jeanine
tu as posé
bonsoir les hommes les critères
extrêmement bien membré enchères
rodriguez vérifie tout ça m'attriste de
bruitages depuis plus de 150 ans et ne
pouvait venir chez vous pour faire des
bruitages de style touche pas à mon
poste
bonjour mes petites nouveautés oh là là
quelle d'arca devancera ont tué nos
bases à maurice
merci au case mate patrick chirac
[Applaudissements]
alors on attend pas patrick
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais beau me wade a remis au travail
et les enfants à tuer l'agent denis
barthe envie ouais j'en ai basra bojan
vie de ses potes donc voulu garder une
merveille merci oui c'est vrai qu'il est
capable de les bonbonnes de magazines
rabon maillot nîmois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
post 12 jours de la semaine à benno
besson la série jean michel mr inouï
[Musique]
jean michel maire
un prochain pronostiqueurs officiel de
la coupe du monde de foot sera renom le
chien non voyants achille le chats
sourds basile le perroquet sans pattes
ou verdez le pigeon sans plus
[Musique]
sophie qui te manque toit est flamand
flavie flament a vraiment plus sa valeur
à castanet
ils veulent en plus en plus à la pâte en
ya six ans maintenant la pension
alimentaire et maxime gaming
trois niveaux de salaires pour les
danseurs et d'ajouter il ya les grandes
stars de la télé les plus connus ceux
qui sont en train de le devenir et les
anonymes voilà il ya trois créneaux et
trois prix à peu près alors c'est quoi
alors les chiffres
[Rires]
alors c'est quoi les chiffres ont baissé
dans les environs de 700 m attendais pas
l'effet le plus long de la semaine
moi j'ai mon idée cent mille sa datcha h
et le chat cagoule pour leur voiture
personnelle
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on va embêter le
ménage le pigeon simplement omis ou pas
la non tirer bat à sa place aujourd'hui
donc tu peux nous faire un petit achille
h si la salle a7
olala dernier trophée le ba ba du poste
de la meilleure vannes est dénommée son
vous êtes dedans
non c'est alors où il ya une erreur sur
ma fiche
[Musique]
jean michel maire
quelque chose de nimani terre je vois
partir du fric vous ferai quelque chose
avec des habits en sang en afrique mais
c'est écrit sur cette mesure matthieu
delormeau
mais toi tu insu sur le site gentil jean
luc lemoine
je crois que vous avez été approché il
ya deux ans pour représenter la france à
l'eurovision
est ce que c'est le cas et bien sûr le
passé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
roanne battu à bâle matthieu delormeau
il a fait avec les affrontements entre
les jambes si l'on fait un grand honneur
à